CHRIS HELLMANN: Hello and
welcome to the one before last
session on privileged access.
That's why I brought
the [? Politsi ?]
tee shirt to give you, not
there, not there, we go there.
So it has to be organized.
So we've got a panel of
illustrious people here.
So we got Diana from Vodafone.
We've got Paul Kinlan
from Google.
We've got Petro Soininen--
PETRO SOININEN: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS HELLMANN: OK.
Fair enough.
ex Nokia and now at Five.
And as we didn't have enough
blanket statements and
outrageous swearing, we actually
brought Brian Leroux
from PhoneGap with us as well
who is actually going to start
the whole session by
telling us-- for 10
minutes and not longer--
what we are all about here
about privileged access.
So take it away.
Take your closed technology and
show us what you can do.
BRIAN LEROUX: OK.
Can you guys hear
me all right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah.
Well except for old man Russell
in the front there.
So I'm going to talk to you guys
today about privileged
applications, packaged
applications, sometimes we
call them installable
web applications.
I've even heard it called
a thick client.
So--
oh come on pointer events.
There we go.
I work on a PhoneGap project
which you may have heard of.
It's for building apps using
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
And it's very much like a
packaged application.
You host the assets
on a device and
we load them locally.
They're intrinsically offline.
And it's also a powerful
extensibility layer.
So PhoneGap lets you get
at, basically, anything
the device can do.
And that's what we're
talking about.
So the question that we were
posing was, did the web solve
cross platform?
And I think when it comes to
things like screen sizes and
operating systems, the
web did solve cross
platform really well.
Somebody was talking about Steve
Jobs earlier when he
said, you're going to build
apps and you're going
to build web apps.
And I love that.
I thought that was
a great vision.
But web didn't solve
everything.
Web intrinsically is sandboxed,
and this is
actually not a bug.
This is a feature.
This is how the web works.
But because it has this
capability or this feature
that it's sandboxed, it
also doesn't have
access to device APIs.
And so it's at a disadvantage
when it comes to native
applications.
It's sandboxing.
I guess another disadvantage
of the web is that it can't
participate in app stores
which maybe
we'll talk about later.
I don't think this is exactly
what packaged
applications are all about.
So I don't know if you guys have
noticed but there's this
trend lately towards web
operating systems.
Google's got Chrome OS.
Microsoft has Windows 8, which
uses HTML, CSS, and JavaScript
to build applications.
Some guys called Mozilla
are doing a thing
called Firefox OS.
There's this thing called Tizen,
which is an open source
web operating system by
Samsung and Intel.
And then there's
Web OS from HP.
It kind of makes me sad so
I don't like to talk
about it too much.
But there's all these things.
So if you think about Google,
Microsoft, Mozilla, Samsung,
Intel, and HP are all betting
on the web for their next
operating systems which is a
pretty interesting thing.
And these are all privileged
applications and packaged
applications.
Mobile is not quite so kind, but
luckily, with PhoneGap we
can get to these things
and we can get
inside these app stores.
And this is not a cheap shot--
this is just a statement of
fact and it's kind
of interesting--
all of these app stores
themselves are web
applications.
They're hybrid apps.
You can't install an
application without the network.
And typically when you're
browsing for apps in an app
store, you're going
to the web.
So forgive me if you've heard
this before because packaged
apps are not a new concept.
This has been around
a long time.
It used to be widgets
inside of Vodafone.
There's this thing called
confabulator from Yahoo.
Think it was Yahoo.
PETRO SOININEN: Yeah.
BRIAN LEROUX: It was Yahoo.
Maybe this thing called AIR
from this other company.
I can't remember who they are.
The idea has been around
for a while though and
it's not a new thing.
So apps that are designed for
a particular platform are
incompatible by their nature.
If you build for a particular
operating system, you're not
going to ship it on other
operating system unless you
believe Blackberry 10, you can
put Android apps on it but
that's another thing
all together.
So that's why we
have standards.
That's the point of
web standards.
And there's actually some
emergent standards that are
around this, and there's
some older ones too.
So there's a thing called the
Widget Spec, which kind of
died in a horrible death, but
it's around in its own way.
Bruce is going to cry.
I'm sorry, Bruce.
It's not around anymore.
There's the device API Working
Group at the W3C that thought
we need all these device APIs.
Let's standardize all this
stuff, but they didn't think
about the security model with
enabling things like camera
and contacts and all
these device APIs.
So there's a new group now
called the System Applications
Working Group.
And it's starting with the idea
of the runtime context
and security model.
And I'll talk about that
in a little bit.
So to be really clear, what
we're talking about here is
packaged web applications.
We're not just talking about
packaged applications because
packaged applications
have happened
before and they've failed.
The web is naturally
interoperable.
The web has this DNA where
things are portable, and this
is what we're looking for.
And this is why packaged web
applications are important.
So this is where shit gets
a little bit boring.
Every application, or every
packaged application has to
have a manifest.
And a manifest is going to have
things like your title,
your icon, your license, your
author, the things we need to
know what to display
when we have a
springboard for the app.
But then it starts to get a
little bit more interesting.
It also has to have an origin
because we need to know where
to go to update it, which
kind of comes back
to the offline stuff.
And it also needs to have white
listing for the network
because a packaged application
typically runs local on the
device but it needs to
know where it can
go to go get data.
Packaged applications also have
permissions for features.
We don't want every application
to have access to
your front facing camera, and
so you have to be able to
declare this.
Packaged applications are
also a runtime context.
So in the case of PhoneGap, we
run on the file protocol.
So file://indexHTML is
where we load stuff.
But this means that all these
applications intrinsically can
do cross domain requests, which
is dangerous, which is
why we have to white listing.
The runtime context also has
some weird properties that are
a little bit different than
other types of applications.
So window.open, for example,
might open an in-app browser
instead spawning a new tab.
File system locations can be
different, that kind of thing.
Thank god there's beer.
OK.
So I'm trying to go
quick here, Chris.
Apps live a really
weird lifecycle.
So an application right now in
a browser, you open a tab, it
starts up, you're good to go.
An application running in a
packaged application runs in
kind of these different modes
and so we have online and
offline events.
I'm of the opinion that we
actually need more information
than just online and offline
but we can talk about that
over the beers later.
We also have pause and resume
so there's something called
the page visibility API in the
web but it's a little bit
nascent right now.
And it's the same thing, but
when you're looking at
applications that are running on
a phone, we can put them in
the background.
They may or may not be able
to do anything about that.
Then there's system
notifications.
And so the classic example I
like to give here is a battery
notification event-- if your
battery is about to die, you
might want to back up
your information.
We implemented this in PhoneGap
and unfortunately,
polling the battery drained
the battery.
So we didn't know what
to do to fix that.
This is a property of packaged
applications too.
So there's runtime security
beyond the sandbox and this is
where stuff is most
interesting.
There's things like
network security.
There's encrypted key stores
possibly on some devices where
you can store data on
the phone securely.
And that's where we get
to device APIs.
So I like to put device
APIs into two buckets.
You've got system sensors
and you've got data.
Sensors are things like your
camera, your accelerometer,
your geolocation, and
that kind of stuff.
GPS.
Data is like your file, your
contacts, your media.
That's what we want to get at.
That's what the web
can't do today.
And that's where the web needs
to go if it wants to compete
with the native platforms
that are out there.
And that's why we're seeing
all this work going into
standardization.
So all this stuff is cool and
everybody wants it, but if
we're not careful, we're
going to shoot
ourselves in the face.
And this is why runtime
security
context is super important.
Awesome, right?
I just wanted to use that GIF.
It's all I got.
Thanks.
Do you want to leave that?
CHRIS HELLMANN: It might be a
bit annoying after a while.
Let's just switch to
something nicer.
How do I type Mozilla's hiring?
No.
OK.
It's good when you get the
speakers drunk first because
then they're much faster
than normally.
BRIAN LEROUX: Did
I go too quick?
CHRIS HELLMANN: No.
That's OK.
We've got more time for
questions then.
That's pretty good.
So as you said, it's an
interesting concept because I
spent the last few months now
talking about Firefox OS to
people and talking about
packaged apps to people.
And every time you talk about
web apps and people are like,
what is that?
I don't quite understand it and
it seems to be this hybrid
that people just don't
get around first.
So to start with that, what do
you think is the main thing
that keeps us from having proper
apps that could be, in
terms of privileges,
on par with
native apps at the moment?
Is it an understanding
problem?
Is it that every provider has
a different manifest format?
Is it that people just don't
trust web apps yet?
What do you think is the biggest
barrier that we have
to overcome?
Let's go through
you one by one.
Diana, what do think?
DIANA CHENG: OK.
There are few things.
Application packaging
is an issue.
It's completely fragmented
at the moment.
Yeah.
This is the way I'm supposed
to hold it.
Another issue is security.
So everything that runs
in the browser has to
have limited access.
So as has been mentioned,
[INAUDIBLE] had a different
device APIs.
Working Group had a different
surface [? cope ?] first and
it was called device APIs and
policy working group.
And then the policy bit got
dropped because websites are
intrinsically--
or you have to assume that
they're going to be malicious,
that they can do
a lot of harm.
So they cannot get write
access to a lot
of data on the device.
They need to be sandboxed
and all that.
So we need a different
sort of runtime.
We need a security model.
You know that the new working
group is working on new APIs
that have extended permissions
that will be installable, that
will, hopefully, be certified
by an app
store, will be signed.
And this is one of the
things that is new.
And it's great that we have
implementations like Firefox
OS and they're going to
put this in the wild.
It's not going to
be just specs.
It's going to be an
implementation.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Cool.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So I think the biggest thing
for me is we haven't got a
unified permissions model.
We don't know.
If you're on the open web and
you're kind of driving past a
URL, we haven't got anything
that's even slightly
considered compatible
across browsers.
And I also think we haven't even
dealt with the fact that
a lot of the things that
we want to do in native
applications we want to do
with things like USB.
And we don't even know how
to like opt the user
into access a device.
In Chrome, we've got the ability
to query some device
ID to see if it's present on the
USB bus and then you can
open it up and read
and write to it.
But we're still trying to make
sure that we've got that
permissions model quite right.
BRIAN LEROUX: And isn't
that like a
fingerprinting issue too?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
Well, that's actually why it
changed relatively recently.
Well, not exactly
why it changed.
BRIAN LEROUX: You've
accepted that
fingerprinting is going to happen?
PAUL KINLAN: Well I think
everyone always has to accept
fingerprinting at some point
is going to happen.
You can look at the EFF website
or whatever it is and
they'll show you all the unique
characteristics of your
normal browsing session.
The thing from the USB side of
things is that we're trying to
get to this place where, maybe
in the manifest, you say that
this application can have access
to your Fitbit or those
types of different devices
because you normally have a
vendor ID and a product ID.
And then that might actually put
people off from actually
installing the application,
especially if
they don't have it.
So we're starting to also move
to this idea of a runtime
permissions model for those
types of things.
And I don't think any of the
browser vendors have even got
to any level of consistency.
That's my biggest thing.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Cool.
PETRO SOININEN: I think for me
it's the thing that even if
you actually understand what
the hybrid concept or the
package web app concept is, is
that a lot of the customers
that we work with just say that
they don't have enough
experience or enough examples
of packaged web apps that
actually do deliver the
UX that they're
going to be happy with.
So I think that we still lack
real showcases and real kick
ass applications that
actually deliver.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Which is quite
bizarre because seeing that
even in the native markets,
a lot of them are actually
packaged apps with PhoneGap.
They're just not advertised
as those.
BRIAN LEROUX: That's right.
Yeah.
CHRIS HELLMANN: And some AIR
ones as well, funnily enough.
BRIAN LEROUX: Tons.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Yeah.
So the questions to moderator
are actually all going around
the same topic, which is the
biggest topic that everybody
has to deal with, how do I make
my end users realize that
they're giving permission
right now?
Do we really need to ask for
permission for everything?
And how do we make sure we don't
overload people with a
question every time they
do one action?
Do you want to move
the mouse left?
Are you sure?
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah.
CHRIS HELLMANN: These
kind of things.
Where do we draw the line?
What is the real problem
with that?
BRIAN LEROUX: This is the key
issue to me because we don't
want to have web Vista where
it's like asking permission
for everything.
Can I access your camera?
Can I access your contacts?
Can I use your file system?
That user experience
would totally suck.
At the same time, we don't want
the user experience to be
website XXX has access to my
front facing camera and my
contacts, and yeah, we don't
have to go any further with
that analogy to know that
that's a bad thing.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Speak
for yourself.
BRIAN LEROUX: So browser vendors
are challenged by this
too because I think Google's
proposing something.
They're trying to come up with
language in the system
applications working group.
How do we have this thing called
like a trust gesture
where you say to the browser,
hey, I trust this thing maybe
one time, or I trust it
for all the time.
We wanted to be able to get back
to those permissions and
look at them and maybe revoke
them possibly in case website
XXX turns a new leaf.
CHRIS HELLMANN: It's also
no timely access.
It always seems like it would
be a black and white thing.
I give access and that's it,
but I could grant, for
example, a guest pass for an
app to access my camera for
the next five minutes and then
I have to revoke that again,
or it revokes automatically.
I mean, Flickr had this for
guest access to your photos,
for example, that you could
send somebody a string and
like within an hour they could
look at your stuff but after
an hour they can't
login anymore.
That would be another
way of dealing with
that, wouldn't it?
That I could say, OK, for the
next five minutes I want to
try that app out but after that,
you don't get access to
the camera anymore.
PAUL KINLAN: I mean, we could,
but that exists anyway, right,
in the sense that if you do a
get-user media it normally
pops up a little bar
across the top.
It's because the hardware
manufacturer actually puts a
little LED at the front so you
know it's on, it's actually
doing stuff.
But once you actually finish
with the stream, then it
closes down.
The next time that you request
it you get the
prompt again normally.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: I don't know.
I look at kind of having to
re-grant storage permissions
and increase storage.
People just press the buttons
normally and we don't know
what's going to happen, right?
BRIAN LEROUX: That's the
Android problem.
It's like, oh, this app wants
to do everything.
Cool.
Install.
That's what happens.
Then, later on, you don't know
what permissions you've
granted this thing because you
can't find it because it's
buried in the system.
CHRIS HELLMANN: One good
question was also when you
look at Facebook, for example,
you can give access to
everything in the world.
Then this app turns out to be
evil and you can actually stop
that access.
So you have a dashboard of all
the apps and what access they
have to which device.
So there's a centralized
way of doing that.
Would that be a solution that
we could think about?
That instead of every app having
to ask these things, I
have a dashboard of this
app has access
to these five things.
So you have one grid on your
system that actually allows
you to control all of that.
PETRO SOININEN: Yeah.
I think I'm in this on
the previous kind of
proposal that you make.
They both make sense.
And there are a lot of
other good ideas on
this front as well.
But I think one of the key
things is also just to make
sure that users actually
understand what are they
accepting and then, again,
the mechanisms--
how they can actually
control it.
So as you said, that they're
probably just going to be
pressing the OK, OK, OK and
not really think about it.
But that's not really
technology.
It's more like psychology and
trying to figure out how
humans think.
BRIAN LEROUX: Paul , you were
talking about this at lunch.
You guys had difficulty with
the messaging or something.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
If you look at the way that we
have our installable kind of
hosted apps and packaged apps
in the next packaged apps,
essentially, we have had kind
of this messaging issue.
If you go to install the
application, and you're on,
say, the detail page, it'll
tell you all the
things that it does.
I don't know how many users
actually look at that.
But when you press install,
there are at least three
different levels of ways that
we prompt the user.
So for some things like
unlimited storage, which is a
permission that you can have,
we don't even tell the user.
It's just kind of assumed.
There is, to your point before,
there's actually a
dashboard inside Chrome where
you can normally access like
the levels of permissions that
your applications have and
revoke them.
But normally, when you revoke
something, it means
uninstalling the application.
So that's a different
part as well.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Is it
an innovation thing?
Because we had app cache, then
we had local storage, then we
have Nxdb, then we got web SQL,
and we put an interface
for each of them in the browser
rather than having one
interface for storage and saying
OK, this app wants to
store stuff offline, wants to
store things in a database,
and wants to store things
only for this session.
Do you want to allow this?
Is it now the time to actually
look at all the browsers again
and find a unified interface
for that?
PAUL KINLAN: I mean, there's
also this idea of quota system
which has been banging around
for a little while.
You can request some storage
or an increase in unlimited
storage, for instance, and
it goes across all of the
different types of persistence
mechanisms that you have
inside the browser.
BRIAN LEROUX: Is that
the Quota API?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
These things exist.
We just don't think we've
got consensus
amongst the vendors yet.
I don't know what we do
other than talk more.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Diana,
you wanted to--
DIANA CHENG: Yeah.
I just wanted to say with
regards to that, it's a
difficult thing to agree on
because there is no place to
agree on that.
So this is not something you
can write on a spec.
Right?
On the spec you write things
that are testable, that are
verifiable, but you don't
test UI stuff.
Even in geolocation there was
only so much we could ask.
You should specify the host of
the site that is requesting
the permission and
you show that.
But it's very, very hard to find
a place where you make
people agree on this.
CHRIS HELLMANN: So during lunch,
we talked about widgets
already and I remember
both Vodaphone--
I worked back then on it-- and
Opera were the first ones to
do W3C widgets to actually
have little apps on your
desktop that can run even
when Opera was closed.
So that didn't take on.
Why do you think?
We needed the app model on
mobile phones for people to go
back to the app idea?
Or is it just that on a desktop
nobody understood the
concept of having an app that
actually is in web standards?
PAUL KINLAN: I don't know what
the official answer is, but
it's like just generally
widget was a
weird word, for one.
It didn't denote anything like
an installable application for
me at least when I was
looking at it.
BRIAN LEROUX: I believe they're
an evangelism team.
AUDIENCE: At the time somebody
begged them to change the
stupid name.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
If you look at the spec, a lot
of this stuff is very similar
across all the manifests that we
have apart from it's an XML
and not in the JavaScript
notation.
It's kind of interesting.
CHRIS HELLMANN: So one question
that people had was,
now that every single app
platform, like packaged app
platform in HTML has a different
manifest file, is
there a way to actually
automate that?
Is there already a script
out there--
PAUL KINLAN: Appmeter.com.
CHRIS HELLMANN: --to generate
all of them?
PAUL KINLAN: Yep.
We made one called Appmeter
which did Chrome apps, that
was very specific to Chrome apps
but Firefox apps aren't
too dissimilar.
I think, Bruce, you had one?
Or you--
AUDIENCE: Scott Wilson from
Apache Project had--
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
translate Chrome.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
There's been a couple of these
ones where the core
functionality in most
of the browsers is
pretty much the same.
We are diverging now a little
bit where we're starting to
get more hardware access.
But we're still, as an industry,
exploring what that
means and kind of what
that entails.
But yeah, we've had the ability
to kind of convert
between them but I've not seen
a huge appetite for it.
BRIAN LEROUX: We've got a
library called Confetti in the
PhoneGap project that
will spit out all
the different formats.
So instead of trying to push
an agenda on one format, we
just decided we would
support all of them.
CHRIS HELLMANN: It's interesting
because the apps
themselves are they
that different?
It's like, can you just build
one app and just render it on
all the different platforms?
Because if we're not
inter-compatible in HTML5
itself, then we can not really
tell the native clients off
that they're on.
DIANA CHENG: Besides from the
manifest format, I don't know.
I mean, the technologies
are the same.
It's a package directory.
And I think since Alex is at the
front that maybe this is
something that TAG could
address, like the
fragmentation, in terms
of packaging format.
It's a long term problem in the
W3C and it would be good
to find solutions.
BRIAN LEROUX: Save the
internet, Alex.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Yeah so we've got different APIs
at the moment as well.
Fundamentally, I think Mozilla's
got the web API
system and we've got our
own Chrome name space.
Until that kind of settles down
and we know exactly what
we need from APIs.
A normal web application, like
something that you would
expect to get in your browser
but that's got a little bit of
installability and all this type
of stuff, we've probably
got broadly compatible across
a lot of these platforms.
It's when you get to these new
bits like UDP, TCP, USB,
Bluetooth, these things that
people want from their native
applications, but we don't
have access to
them inside the browser.
We have to work on that
all together.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Shouldn't
they already want to?
Isn't the big problem that I
can't take a photo at the
moment across browsers?
Aren't we already thinking about
the hard projects where
we don't even have parity with
native apps at the moment?
PAUL KINLAN: I mean, the latest
browsers we can take
photos and we can save
them in the gallery.
We can do these things.
We might have not done a greater
job at evangelizing
these bits--
CHRIS HELLMANN: Well then,
do it in the iPhone.
PAUL KINLAN: You can, in the
latest one, I think.
BRIAN LEROUX: You can.
Media capture is there.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Input type.
BRIAN LEROUX: It's [INAUDIBLE]
user media but it's input type
in the camera.
It declared [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS HELLMANN: OK.
Question there?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[? Jonas Sicking ?]
from Mozilla.
I've done a lot of work on that
platform for Firefox OS
including the web
APIs and so on.
One of the reasons we don't have
compatible manifests, is
that we haven't actually
tried.
The device API group went off
and did all the APIs but it's
kind of like they came at it
from the wrong way of not
doing the runtime first which
is why there was no common
ground to sort of build these
things on top of it.
The sys apps working group is
the first real time we're
actually trying to standardize
the packaging format, the
runtime model.
There are proposals a couple
of them including one from
Mozilla for defining a
standardized manifest and
packaging format and so on.
I also wanted, since I
have the microphone--
the app model in Firefox
OS is absolutely not
packaged apps only.
We do a lot to enable web
applications to run just like
a normal website runs today, but
as much as possible enable
it offline, which it's not quite
there yet but we are
hoping to get it there.
BRIAN LEROUX: I honestly don't
think it's an issue either.
It's just a metafile format.
And it's kind of the
most boring bits.
The permissions is going to be
the thing that needs be solved
and the rest of it's like
where's your app icons and
what's the title on the
springboard and that type of
thing which is--
PAUL KINLAN: There's also the
point that [? Jonas ?]
mentioned a second
ago is offline.
That was like the very first
thing that we tried to do in
the next version of Chrome Maps
is make sure the offline
is kind of deep like baked in
completely, which means that
we've gone away on that side of
things from like the hosted
model right now.
But we thought that was the
biggest thing because if you
move into phones and iPad,
iPhone, and Android, it's a
different development model.
You're offline straight away and
then you need [? to put ?]
online functionality
into your app.
And we believe that, at least
for installable apps right
now, that's the way we
should be going.
CHRIS HELLMANN: One question
here is, to go back into the
UX what everybody asked about,
how do we ensure that people
know the impact of what
they're granting?
How do we make sure that people
don't go through the
Android way of like yeah,
yeah, yeah, I give you
everything because I want to
throw these birds at those
pigs or whatever?
Isn't it the problem
that we have?
Like already the press is saying
that HTML5 will never
be secure and native is secure
and when we start actually
advertising like, yeah, there's
things you shouldn't
give grant access to.
Would there be a bad backlash
towards the platform?
BRIAN LEROUX: It's an education
issue absolutely.
We have to teach people what
these things mean.
And I think we're going to have
to teach people how to
use their devices in
a responsible way.
And that's probably going to,
unfortunately, take a massive
privacy fail before we can truly
appreciate how important
these things are.
DIANA CHENG: One thing that many
people claim, and that I
actually agree for
certain APIs is
through keeping the locality.
So the relationship between the
permission and the action
that needs this permission makes
it clearer to the user.
So having an API that allows you
to specify up front for a
website or web app what are all
of the permissions and for
the user to approve them in a
batch might not be the best
for all applications.
It could work in many cases.
If I just want your
location, then why
would I ask this upfront?
I want to be asked for this when
I actually want to see my
location with relation to
my car in a map, right?
So that helps the
user, I think.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Well,
that's the power of
the web, isn't it?
The immediacy and the on demand
delivery of content and
on demand delivery
of functionality.
Whereas, with packaged
apps and native apps,
we don't have that.
It's like one app per thing
that does it perfectly.
That's fine but I have to
install an app to convert
Celsius and Fahrenheit where I
could enter that in Google in
the search bar as well and
get the same result.
So the question is, how do we
make people aware that the web
apps can't do more than that?
With packaged apps, don't we
just simulate what the other
apps are doing but we don't
have the same access to
hardware and we can't give
the same experience?
BRIAN LEROUX: Well, with the
PhoneGap hack we're just
utilizing what the operating
system does.
So in the case of Apple,
the security
model is to be reviewed.
In the case of Android, the
security model is to have a
permissions manifest.
And then that's all we can do.
Chrome apps, Windows 8 apps,
all these new web operating
systems, Firefox OS, this is the
opportunity to define this
and teach people.
So basically what I'm saying is,
that's your guys' problem.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Because the
issue is I scare a lot of
users off when I just show
them like I want to have
access to 20 things.
This app can do this
and that and that.
Whereas, if the usage of the app
is basic and later on they
go to other levels and
need more access.
And then, the question
should come.
But that's again, a UX
problem, isn't it?
PAUL KINLAN: I don't know.
You have to work it out.
It's actually a really complex
problem because you've got
different times that you might
want elevated access, like the
unlimited storage one is we can
let you know at install
time that this application's
got unlimited storage.
I don't think we do at the
moment for that one, but there
are other ones like when you can
do cross domain requests
without breaking out the normal
site, like the sandbox,
like the domain isolation
at least.
We let you know at install time
that this application can
do that, but it all depends
on the message that we do.
If you put one or two sites
in, we'll tell you you can
access Twitter.com, it
can access Facebook.
But if you put 10 different
like domain sources in, we
basically say this application
can access the
content of your sites.
Because you can't list all 20.
And especially when it's like
a weird regular expression
which is *.Facebook.com/*.
Like normal users aren't going
to even know what that means.
They're just going to see some
weird stuff when they install
it which increases the
likelihood that they'll just
click OK without understanding
the ramifications.
AUDIENCE: I believe greatly in
the belief you should give
control to users.
This is a question regarding
to the permission system.
So I'm wondering about the
problem with education
regarding the user.
The problem I see is that
there's no control to use
actually at the moment.
Users giving a question
regarding giving access to all
of these permissions without
[INAUDIBLE] actually giving
updates set on the specific
permissions.
They don't wan to give access
to contacts, for example.
I think that should
be possible.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Yeah.
The question is you have to give
all permissions and if
you don't give one of them, you
just don't get the app,
rather than it should be up to
you which ones to give and the
app should apply to that or
the app should change
accordingly?
BRIAN LEROUX: I think Chrome
got this [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL KINLAN: We're exploring
that at the moment where you
can request access.
Basically, it's an optional
permission where you can
request access.
You have it in the manifest so
you know the application's at
least going to ask for
it at some point.
And then when you come to ask
for it, you can ask the user
are they sure they want
to do this action.
I think the problem it comes
down to is, one, it's
relatively awkward to tell
developers to go and do this
and the easier one is just to
put the non-optional optional
permissions in.
It all depends on the
functionality
of the app as well.
If the app can live with
it, then it's fine.
If it can't live with it, what's
the point of installing
the app if you need access to
the camera and then every so
often you don't give access
to the camera.
I don't quite know.
CHRIS HELLMANN: In Firefox
OS, we've got
three different levels.
We've got an app that you host
yourself which only has access
to the things that the browser
has in there now as well like
local storage and geolocation.
And then we have an app that
has to go through the
marketplace and we have an app
that only Mozilla and partners
can do that get access to like
telephony and sending text
messages and things.
Is that a good idea or is it
maybe something other people
should mimic?
Because the one size fits all,
that app can access everything
or nothing, is not getting us
anywhere at the moment.
People want to host things on
their own server but they also
want to get access
to the hardware.
BRIAN LEROUX: I like
that model too.
I think these things
are compatible.
If people happen to be running
Chrome right now, you could
click on the favicon icon, and
you can get this contacts menu
in your desktop browser that
shows you all these different
permissions.
And I think this is the early
manifestation of these ideas,
but it is an all or nothing.
You don't have this idea of
different levels of privilege,
the system apps, user apps, wild
west apps, I guess, would
be the third part.
And then there's like the idea
of federation in app stores.
So right now app stores are all
walled gardens per vendor,
essentially, but it
makes no sense.
Why is EA getting permission
from Apple to ship a game?
It's crazy, right?
EA should have its own store.
I trust EA.
I want to play games.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Well if only we
had an open marketplace API
but I'm not going to talk about
that now, but you can
ask me later.
What is interesting about this
is that you said like I trust
EA, but you can't trust
any server.
It doesn't really matter
who it is.
It's like larger companies
can get their
service hacked as well.
It's just a matter of
how do you do it
unless you host it yourself?
And that, to me, is the main
crux of the matter.
I just got an update on an
Android app that asked me for
1.81 gig update.
And you're like, you haven't
understood mobile devices, did
you because I only got 8 gig
on this machine anyway.
So how could we do an app that
are already granted access to
allow it to update
automatically, to only get
parts, to load a new level, to
load to new extra in a game
rather than replace the whole
packaging system?
I think that is failing
on the web.
I don't want to download
an app every
time there is a change.
But the change should be in
an extra API somehow.
BRIAN LEROUX: That's an
imperative API for the cache
manifest would do that.
So you could do delta updating
which I think is the stuff
that Alex and Jake have
been proposing.
Yeah.
It's a big issue.
So PhoneGap apps have this
one all the time.
We have a game and that game
could be gigabytes.
They only want to load the first
level because you want
to be available over the network
and if the user gets
to level two in whatever game
they're playing, then download
those assets then.
It's a huge issue for sure.
AUDIENCE: I think when we were
talking on the permission
stuff, I can give a very short
run down on what we're doing
in Firefox OS, which is we
essentially have two types of
privileges for APIs.
We have APIs where the user gets
asked the question very
similar to GPS and
geolocation.
But there's a lot of APIs where
we just can't ask the
user, like asking the user do
you want to allow this app to
use TCP socket?
It doesn't mean anything.
So for those types of APIs where
we didn't feel we could
ask the user, we have to do it
through a review process which
is very unfortunate.
Because it does mean that it's
much more similar to the iOS
model where it has to be someone
that is a trusted
party that has actually
done code reviews.
Code reviews doesn't really work
but it's kind of the only
thing we have right now.
We sort of have a third model
where it has to go both
through code review and we ask
the user where the code review
sort of covers the security
aspect and the asking the user
covers the privacy aspect.
But these are sort of
the models we have.
The code review part does mean
that it has to be a packaged
app because that's the only
way to ensure that the
reviewed code is what's actually
being executed.
But that's something we'd like
to figure out but this is the
first iteration.
CHRIS HELLMANN: One question
also on moderator was an
interesting one that says, I
trust the cam app from Google.
Why don't we have apps that are
trusted for the access and
go through those rather
than having
the app itself contacted?
I don't want to put the dagger
in but Web Intents did
something like that,
didn't it?
Because I already knew I had
stuff on my mobile phone that
I could take pictures with.
Why can't I get the picture
from that app rather than
having to ask for permission
to access the camera?
Web activities do that, and in
the browser, input type camera
does the same thing.
But an app cannot access it
the same way as far as I
understand it.
Wouldn't that be a way around
that every operating system
comes with apps that are trusted
for different access
to different parts and
it goes through a
security level that way?
BRIAN LEROUX: Do it, Paul.
Go.
PAUL KINLAN: I actually
don't know the answer.
People want natively integrated
experiences like
inside their app.
They would like the camera to
be there so that they can
apply a little fish-eye effect
to it and make their face look
big and all these types of
things in real time.
And we could go down the Intent
model of you delegate
the functionality to a
trusted application.
That's fine, but people want
to integrate it into their
experience, and I don't
know how you delegate
between both scenarios.
Maybe have an activity
Intent-like system at
the same time as--
I don't know.
I think people get confused by
having to switch between apps
all the time.
If you're having all
this functionality.
I don't know.
You've got to get broad
consensus across every single
different type of platform
about well
how do I access contacts?
Do I go to the contact kind
of like contact manager?
Well, obviously if we have 10
different types of contact
managers, it's a desktop
machine and all
this type of stuff.
I don't know.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Especially
with contacts it's an
interesting one because the
interface is optimized for
doing contacts so why should
any app build their own
contact manager on
top of that?
PAUL KINLAN: Well it's not
necessarily contact manager.
It's like people want to share
invites to their friends on
different networks and all
this type of stuff.
There's loads of different use
cases where you want to
integrate it directly into the
experience and that's why you
don't delegate out.
CHRIS HELLMANN: We had
a twitch over there.
Munir, did you want
to say something?
MUNIR: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS HELLMANN: As you see in
the Firefox tee shirt, he
actually works on the
web APIs as well.
MUNIR: [INAUDIBLE].
So I'd actually [INAUDIBLE]
exactly solving the issue you
are mentioning.
If an app can't do something,
[INAUDIBLE] are doing
something, permissions or
something, like sending an SMS
in Firefox OS, only the
system can do that.
You can just call that web
[INAUDIBLE] and system app
already has some behavior that
is secure like showing the
[INAUDIBLE].
So all activity should
resolve [INAUDIBLE]
where not want to
do some issue.
Web Intent has [INAUDIBLE]
or Intent on Android.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Another
question we had, what
granularity should permissions
be at?
Obviously having separate
permissions for app cache and
local storage is overkill,
but do we need any
granularity at all?
Would a single privilege status
be enough, like can
take photos, can't take live
video, for example?
Shall we complicate this more
than it is already?
DIANA CHENG: I was going to say
granularity makes UI very
complicated.
And that's something we want
to avoid because developers
don't like presenting
prompts to the user.
That has been proven.
They want to avoid it.
So the more complicated the UI,
the least developers are
going to want to use
any APIs really.
PETRO SOININEN: Yeah.
I think it comes down to what
Paul said earlier that if you
start having gazillion lines
in your prompt asking about
cryptic things no one is
going to understand
what it actually means.
So there has to be a way to
try to keep it simple and
actually understandable
for the user.
CHRIS HELLMANN: It's an
interesting task for the UX
people out there, isn't it?
It's like how to explain
something that complex in very
simple words and then translate
it into foreign
languages as well.
PETRO SOININEN: Yeah.
Plus when you take into account
potential kind of
different legislation
in some areas.
For example, in China you might
have totally different
requirements on what kind of
privacy things you actually
need to ask from the user.
And for example, if you
use the same service
in Germany or whatever.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Yeah.
PETRO SOININEN: Quite
a complex issue.
CHRIS HELLMANN: You can't ask
for gender in Germany, for
example, these kinds
of things.
Yeah.
DIANA CHENG: When it should
arise is also what happens
when the application changes.
When the application gets
changed, if it needs a higher
level or a more specific
level of granularity.
For example, for your location,
we thought OK,
asking for the exact location
all the time when only the
city is relevant.
It's too much.
Why shouldn't we ask for just
city, country, whatever?
Then what happens when the
app actually needs more
information?
They need to prompt
the user again.
Or for a different action in the
same app, 15 minutes later
then you are prompting the user
again for a more specific
permission and that's
not good.
CHRIS HELLMANN: It's
tricky, isn't it?
It all [INAUDIBLE]
to me it seems like we're not
going to solve this one here,
but I love the idea of any app
having access to a permissions
controller that actually would
control all the permissions
possible and actually allow you
to unset, set them, get
new permissions in, and
basically separate that from
your main app.
Because right now, we have to
bake it in somehow and that
just feels like it
doesn't scale and
it's not future proof.
Has anybody thought of that?
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah and it's also
really closely tied to a
capability model.
So this is another problem that
we're running into pretty
often where we'll have devices
that don't have a camera and
someone will ship an app in an
app store and that app will
utilize camera functionality.
And right now our answer
is that we just fail.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Trying to detect
a camera that isn't
there unless you ship
it with the app.
BRIAN LEROUX: Right.
Yeah.
Buy this app, get
a free camera.
AUDIENCE: Just an observation
about granularity
permissions, really.
It seems that there's no
value in asking a user
can I use index TB?
Can I use local storage?
Can I use app cache?
Because they don't care.
But then something we thought
about in Opera was with like
geolocation.
So we could imagine, for
example, that somebody like a
woman living on her own might
wish to say yeah my tweets can
have my location between 10:00
AM and 6:00 PM but I don't
want my tweets to have my
location after 6:00 PM because
I'm probably at my house.
CHRIS HELLMANN: So Geo-Fencing
that Flickr has?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
And one of the things that we
looked at as well about a
console where you
can look at the
permissions you've granted.
You very rarely want to see what
permissions did I give to
Mr. Spanky dot DE,
for example.
But you might very well--
sorry, Brian--
you might very well want
to say what things
can look at my camera?
So the question of which way
around the grid goes.
You probably care.
Oh, shit!
What can look at my camera much
more than what have I
given every individual URL
or app, for example.
And there's also with a camera,
of course, there's an
argument for having a big
kill switch so nothing
can look at my camera.
Because obviously you cover the
camera on your phone or
your laptop, but there's no
guarantee that it isn't
actually a camera that's out of
reach that's plugged into
your laptop and you might want
to have a kill thing.
PAUL KINLAN: So one of the
interesting things about that
is I don't know whether we're
assuming that these
applications run inside the
browser, but a lot of the
stuff that especially we're
doing with Chrome applications
is that you don't know they're
actually even slightly tied to
Chrome in the slightest.
So if you're going to have a
permissions model, you're not
going to put it inside your
browser for someone to go in
there and disable it.
And I don't know what type of
operating system level.
We don't control
Windows, right?
So we couldn't put that in.
So we have to go and add a
settings app, for instance, if
we're going to do that type
of thing it's hard.
Yeah, just hard.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Which brings
us to this one here.
What do packaged apps with their
close ties to particular
browsers and web app stores mean
for cross browser as a
platform support?
As I said before, it's like we
always say in HTML5 you write
it once and it works everywhere
and then like
actually that app store doesn't
allow you to do that,
that one doesn't allow
you to do that.
So can't we all just
get along?
When PhoneGap came out,
it said clearly
this is a gap solution.
We want to be redundant sooner
or later and it's been now
four years?
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah.
Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: But what's
it mean for
across browser support?
That's the question I've got.
If you've package this thing
up to be a deliverable--
it's like Adobe AIR, right?
When you could package a
[INAUDIBLE] on JavaScript it
would run with a really
old version of WebKit.
Does the user know?
Does the user care?
Would they know it's Firefox and
not Firefox that's ruling
the renderer?
If you've got installable apps,
there are installable
apps which are technically
isolated from the browser.
I don't know.
And if you talk about things
inside the browser, then
that's a different
question again.
BRIAN LEROUX: I think with
renderer things have gotten
pretty clean at this point
because of one of the, I
think, biggest triumphs of HTML5
was defining the parser.
So now all browsers have the
same bugs and we don't need to
worry about cross browser
compatibility.
This is just the new
part that's going
to be tough to do.
And there's probably going to be
a jQuery of device APIs at
some point I would assume.
And we're going to have
something that's going to
polyfill all this garbage
and then eventually
standardize that too.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
People are doing it
with Node, right?
So people are building these
Node-based servers which can
talk to AR drones and then go
well I want that to work on,
like a Chrome app.
I want it to work on
the Firefox app.
Well, we'll just port the Node
APIs back across rather than
go and try and learn
the default--
BRIAN LEROUX: Browser find.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Actually, we use browser find
in our project so it's cool.
CHRIS HELLMANN: One question
we also had is why can't I
trust Open Full Screen without
the user having to give me
permission and the keyboard
access in Full Screen and all
the things we had?
That also ties into why can't I
have a video playing in the
background on iOS?
Why it is click to activate?
Education-wise, we probably know
why all of these things
are necessary.
But it is a valid question
for end users.
Why do I get this ugly window
saying this app is now full
screen because yeah, it's an
app, I want it full screen.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It's all based on usage and
use cases and developers
actually wanting these
things, right?
And we didn't prioritize
that originally.
We've added it in so that you
can request a window goes full
screen without any kind
of interstitial.
But it's an installed app.
It's a different thing.
And I don't know whether the
access model from the web
translates to installed apps the
same way, where we have to
have an explicit user gesture
for activities such as across
a site and it just going
automatically to a full screen.
You don't want that on
the drive by web.
But as an installed app,
you're probably fine.
You want your game
full screen.
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah.
It's to avoid fishing.
Essentially because that screen
app could then fake
your Chrome.
It could say, hey, you forget
to put in your bank path.
CHRIS HELLMANN: I think the
best I've ever seen was a
banner that said has your credit
card being stolen?
Please enter your credit
card details here.
That was amazing.
I totally loved that.
So what do you think about
a model that allows you a
certain amount, like you can
store five photos without
asking for permission.
Is that a possibility that we
have tried to buy permissions
and then when they like it, it
seems like you want to store
bigger photos.
Please give us access to the
rest of the hardware.
BRIAN LEROUX: Super
case by case.
But yeah, I like it.
I think it's good.
And this is, for me, also one
of the fundamental issues is
offline storage.
Right now we've got 2 to 5
megs depending on who you
believe which isn't enough
space to do anything
significant.
And so yeah, I think we do
need these piecemeal
permissions to ease people
into the hot tub of it.
Right?
We got to get the
stuff into the
browser as soon as possible.
CHRIS HELLMANN: How
about storage?
I mean, I don't want to go into
index DB versus web SQL.
I'd tell people to
use Lawnchair.
But it's still an issue that
people don't go into web app
development because they
basically say, I don't want to
write for 10 different things.
Why can't your browser
vendors get along?
So what could be an
answer to that?
Use Lawnchair.
Yeah, I know.
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah.
Use Lawnchair-- no, I don't know
what the answer is there.
I think the browser vendors now
work together more than
they ever have.
The new browser war is
essentially consensus.
That's the new battle that's
happening and it's
speed and dev tools.
Those are the things that the
browsers are fighting about.
So we're winning as devs but
there's just all these things
and storage is one of
them that the native
world kicks our ass.
We need to fix that.
CHRIS HELLMANN: OK.
Any last words?
We're almost out of time.
Give us a timeline.
When can we finally have
packaged apps that work
everywhere?
When can you close PhoneGap?
BRIAN LEROUX: I have
no idea, man.
I don't know.
I thought we'd be done
all this by now.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Do you get a
lot of stuff in Adobe that
people from AIR look at you
like we've done this.
Why do you have to reinvent
it right now?
BRIAN LEROUX: Actually, no.
They're awesome.
You could say that the road was
paved pretty easy and we
have a good roadmap to
look forward to.
Stuff that had been done
in the Flash Player and
with AIR for sure.
Yeah, they're cool.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Good.
What do you think will be
the next thing for you
like Chrome app store?
Will there be Chrome packaged
apps for mobile as well?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
If you look on GitHub,
there's a public
repo and it uses Cordova.
It's our easiest avenue to get
a consistent API stuck across
those devices.
The biggest thing for me is like
the API access whether
it's cross browser or not.
It's like the developer doesn't,
in theory, want to
have to care.
We're supposed to be trying to
solve that problem for them
with HTML in general.
But we are at the stage where
everything is brand new and
we've not really done this
device access thing before,
and we're all trying out
slightly different things.
And at some point, we'll get
consensus and we'll have a
nice model.
But we need to prove that
built-in native apps is a
thing that actually is going to
be cool and works, and we
deliver great user experiences
with it.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Do you see a
slight competition between
apps and asking for permissions
and browsers
having things like WebRTC
and things inside?
A lot of people come to me and
saw something on HTML Rocks
like look in the latest
[? cannery ?]
I can also take pictures so why
do you even complain about
this anymore?
It's like desktop browsers seem
to have some things that
mobile browsers just
cannot get.
And as developers, we try to
show off to each other but
don't understand
the difference.
BRIAN LEROUX: I wasn't
even aware.
Is WebRTC really there?
I mean, I know Firefox
and Chrome are
talking to each other.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's coming to--
BRIAN LEROUX: There's
that other browser.
I'm trying to remember,
Internet Explorer.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Or the
Erickson thing.
Yeah.
DIANA CHENG: I tried WebRTC
on Opera mobile.
So [INAUDIBLE] media and it
prompts for permission but it
didn't really work.
It didn't really show
me my stream.
So I don't know why.
Maybe it's implementing a
previous version of the spec
and I'm just asking it.
BRIAN LEROUX: In many ways, all
this is not [INAUDIBLE]
like the world of technology and
the web is advancing to a
point where it is kind of all
hybrid and the differences
between the native stack and
the web stack are getting
blurrier by the second.
I think that it's not going to
be like web versus native,
it's just going to
be development.
Software development
will be of the web.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Web GL is a
good point there as well.
It gives you like full access to
the graphics hardware which
you cannot do from anything else
which CSS shaders will
have the same thing, which
another company it has a
different 3D engine basically
said it's a security problem.
So we're not quite there yet
but we have a lot of
technologies that try to do the
same thing but we don't
seem to be there to
come up with a
standard around that stuff.
So where do you think
we should go next?
Where do you think people
should push us
to actually do things?
I like people complaining and
filing bugs to browsers.
I think they should much, much
more, but they should have a
good ammunition to say this is
the first thing we need.
PAUL KINLAN: I think they've
been saying that
for a while, right?
They want offline
apps to work.
If it's an app, for instance,
they want that to work pretty
much wherever they are
regardless of connection
status and they want
it installed.
They don't want to have to
launch a browser to go and
launch an app to go and do
something that they would
expect to just find on their
desktop and click and open.
I think if we get those two
sorted, we're on a good path
to working the rest out.
And then it's use case
lead from there.
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah, I agree.
Totally.
Those are the biggest
challenges for sure is offline.
Discovery may be another one
too, figuring out this app
store thing.
CHRIS HELLMANN: Yeah.
Because we need a search engine
for app stores by now.
There's far too many
out there already.
It's tricky to actually--
when promoting your app means to
have to go through like 40
different app stores, then
something went very wrong
along the way because we had
the internet already to put
your content out there and get
it found by people like Google
and others.
Well thanks very much.
So next we have tooling.
Cheers!